last month the state of Washington  became the first state to allow the  composting of human bodies this is real  yes that's right this is a real story  until now you could only bury or cremate  a body but now in Washington State you  can compost it and some companies well  they're seeing an opportunity before she  passed on your grandmother loved working  in the garden now she can work in the  garden again introducing Scots memorial  topsoil each bag contains the right  balance of nitrogen phosphorus potassium  and memory every flower and taste her in  every tomato  check out the entire line of Scott's  memorial products including Scott's  memorial Turf Builder Scott's memorial  potting soil and Scott's peat moss made  from actual guys named Pete good luck  don't overwater don't it's not Scott's  memorial soils they really are pushing  up daisies  [Applause]